Is this
place moving?  After all, I
tried to commit suicide, but it seems that you were the only one who crept into the coffin
.
That means your hypothesis is wrong
But then this morning your handwriting wasn't something you were
born with Burns you got when you were just born Advertisers
got it
Hey, it's 0 episodes, but the daughter who should inherit the house is empty
So to
your mother Your parents
chose the pearl to end the bloody history of the empty house
But you were the only one they couldn't kill I'm
going back in time  I can't do it all over again
I've lost the meaning of my life
What are
you talking about Bagger?
Everyone chased me so that I could get better There are
so many
meanings in your life
[music] Once
again happy birthday Come on
[music]
me